when you look at the majority of the
beer produced
around the world today and a lot of it
falls into the categories of things like
american lager american light lager
international pale lager all of those
styles are descended
from this one beer
[Music]
hi i'm pat fahey master cicerone and
content director for the cicerone
certification program and this
is each and every beer style in the wine
world
experts are known as somalias and are
certified by the court of master
sommeliers
the cicerone certification program
serves a similar purpose
in the beer world educating both
professionals
and enthusiasts one of the most
important topics that we cover
in all of our materials is beer styles
and these style guidelines
are usually created primarily for the
purpose of
judging beers in a competition setting
so we're going to
work within those guidelines we're going
to be covering a lot of different
classic styles but we'll also talk about
some of those variations at the end that
brewers use
to produce the wide landscape of beers
that you see today i
broke those styles down into eight
different
groups primarily based on the flavors
that you find in those beers
so we're kicking things off with multi
lagers we've got 19 of them to cover
we're going to see a huge range
of different types of malt flavor malt
flavor
is commonly described as like bakery
flavors because
a lot of the sorts of flavors that you
get in different types of malts
are things that you might see in
different types of baked goods so on the
pale end
you might see things like bread dough
or crackers or like freshly baked bread
and as it ranges and gets darker and
darker we go through flavors like
caramel nutty toffee on into
chocolate and espresso in really really
dark malty beers
we're going to see kind of the whole
range of those flavors here and we're
going to find
that the color of many of these styles
really dictates the sorts of malt
flavors that we're going to see
so during that final phase of the
malting process the grain is first
dried and then the maltster will apply
some amount of additional heat to the
grain to sort of determine
what flavors they want that grain to
have so to kick things off
in the multi-lagers group we're going to
be talking about
american and international lagers and
we're going to start with
a style that's one of the most widely
available beer styles in the world
that's american light locker
think of bud light coors light
miller lite it's a style that's
relatively
light in its overall flavor profile
american lager was
developed before the light lager style
came into being light lagers kind of
came around in like the
mid-1970s but at this point the
light lager style is a lot more popular
of the two of them
they both share a lot in terms of
production processes though a lot of
times they're going to be brewed
using either rice or corn in addition to
barley and that addition of rice or corn
is used to lighten both the color
the malt flavor and the body of those
beers one of the reasons that both
american light locker and american lager
have been so successful
is that they don't have a lot in the way
of identifiable flavors going on
you know they're relatively inoffensive
beers
designed to appeal to a broad swath of
people
the next subgroup is a family of
international loggers and
they're differentiated based on their
color we have international pale lager
international amber logger and
international dark lager
international pale lager is far and away
the most popular member of the group
think beers like heineken corona peroni
asahi super dry you know these are beers
that look a lot like american lagers
they're usually a little bit beefier
they're oftentimes not
going to be made with corn or rice they
could be all malt beverages which is
going to give them a little bit more
body and a little bit more flavor they
also are potentially
bitter to a slightly higher level but
still very approachable beer is easy
drinking
widely enjoyed by people all around the
world so both
international amber lager and
international dark lager are
not seen quite as often for
international amber logger maybe the
most common example you'd see
would be dosakis amber on
the international dark logger side
you're looking at something like uh
shinerbach international amber lager
usually going to have
a little bit more malt character and to
get that amber color
and that's going to give you maybe just
a touch of caramel or toast flavor
international dark lager on the other
hand you might expect that that would
have even more malt character
but a lot of times that color is going
to be the result of some caramel
coloring
oftentimes just like a like a colored
version of an international pay logger
then the last member of this sort of
american lager
family is a beer called cremail
which as the name implies is not
actually a lager
kind of snuck it in here in part just
because the flavor profile is so
similar to what you see in american
lagers cream ales
are often formulated a lot like a normal
strength american lager they're just
going to be fermented with
ale yeast and typically it's going to be
done in a way where you still don't get
very much
in the way of fermentation flavor the
next group that we're going to cover
is a group of multi-european lagers that
are all kind of
normal-ish alcohol strength like the
four and a half to five and a half
percent alcohol range
and well the last group was a little bit
tighter in terms of the flavors that we
saw from the different styles
this one is going to cover a broader
range of different malt
flavors and characteristics first up
we've got muna kellis a
pale lager style from germany and with
german styles
knowing just a little bit of german can
honestly help you understand
a fair amount of the basics of any style
you look at the name of this beard
munich means a beer from munich
helles means light or pale in color so
any beer you see from germany that has
like hell or hellas in the name
is going to be a pale beer muna kelas
today
is the most popular everyday drinking
beer
that you find across bavaria you see
people hoisting huge signs of
pale golden beer it's usually going to
be a liter of helles
it's just an awesome drinking beer next
up is keller beer
keller means cellar and it's it's a
reference to the fact that these beers
are oftentimes just finished fermenting
uh so you get a beer that's a little bit
younger and is typically unfiltered when
it's
served there are different variations of
the style but one of the more common is
just a pale color beer
which is basically an unfiltered version
of munich ellis
the next two styles merits and fest beer
are
very closely tied together and they're
related to kind of the
the traditional oktoberfest celebration
so back in the early 1800s
crown prince ludwig was getting married
they
brought a lot of people together prior
to this wedding
and through just a huge rager
of a beer fest people had such a good
time doing it that they're like you know
what
we should do this every year forever and
that became oktoberfest
originally the beer that was served at
oktoberfest
was this style of beer called merzin
merton means
march like the month of march and this
was a
stronger somewhat dark beer that was
brewed in march typically would have
been
cellared throughout the warmer months of
the year and then enjoyed in october
or late september so it naturally sort
of synced up with this oktoberfest
celebration
however over time consumer tastes have
sort of
shifted to favor beers that are a bit
paler in color
so today when you see oktoberfest's
beer being served at the oktoberfest
celebration they're usually pretty pale
in color
that style is usually referred to as
fest beer the vienna lager style was
developed
in a similar time frame as merits and
was kind of like the early to
mid 1800s and is honestly a pretty
similar beer in terms of its makeup
it's maybe a little bit lighter in color
and a little bit less malty
and balanced slightly more towards
bitterness
but otherwise it's a pretty similar beer
style
the vienna lager style was developed
around the same time as the
merits in style just in vienna instead
of bavaria
ironically enough vienna lager doesn't
really
exist in vienna to an appreciable extent
these days you're
far more likely to find it in the u.s or
even in mexico
next up is munich duncal and going back
to sort of our
translation of german words dukel is the
german word for
dark any beer that you see that's
labeled
as a dukel or has dungle somewhere on
the label
has kind of darker toastier pretzel-like
breadcrust kind of malt flavors to go
along with it
the easiest way to think of munich dukel
is kind of as a dark version of a munich
helix
historically dougal actually came long
before munich ellis did
when you look at beer history the grand
scheme of things
really like pale golden beer is a
relatively recent
invention the first widely available
pale beards didn't come into being until
early to mid 1800's prior to the 20th
century
munich duncan would have been that
everyday drinking beer for
the citizens of bavaria continuing with
our
lesson on german color words schwartz is
the german word for black so schwartz
beer
literally translates to black beer it's
basically just a
darker version of a munich dukel
usually not going to see like tons of
overt heavily roasted character like you
would in a stout things like
coffee and espresso but it'll have kind
of
additional light chocolate flavors in
addition to the toasty notes that you
find in a typical munich vehicle
the final pair of this group are a
couple of
multi-loggers from the czech republic we
have check amber lager
and check dark logger both of these
styles are honestly
pretty difficult to come by outside of
the czech republic and
even can be a bit hard to find if you're
in the czech republic
but if you are able to get your hands on
them they're delightful beers
both of these czech loggers combine sort
of a rich
malt profile with the pronounced level
of bitterness and a bit of spicy hop
aroma
the last subgroup of this multi-lager
family
is the bach beers which itself is a
group
of four higher strength
german lager styles now our german
language skills do
fail us a little bit here the direct
translation of
bach is goat and that's not really
where the name comes from the name is
thought to be
a basically a linguistic corruption of
beer from the city of einbeck however
bach does carry a legal connotation in
germany
beers that are labeled as box are
usually going to be a bit stronger than
your average beer you know at the very
least
usually going to be about six percent
alcohol but some of the members of the
bach family can range all the way up to
alcohol the first member of the family
we're going to talk about is douglas
bach
as we already talked about dunkel means
dark so this is basically a
strong dark lager uh today it's one of
the least seen members of the family
next up is helispock which is a pale
strong lager hellisbach also is
sometimes referred to as mybach
my translating to the month of may
and hella spock or mybach is a is a
common
spring seasonal beer in germany
helsbach looks a lot like a stronger
version
of a munich though it does usually
feature a little bit of hot flavor and
aroma but given its
rather high strength it's it's actually
a pretty refreshing beer
doppelbock today is essentially a higher
strength version
of a regular dunkel's bach and of all of
these box sub styles
it's the most widely available style the
original doppelbach beer
was a beer from the polynomial in
germany known as salvatore they still
make that beer today
to this day a lot of breweries
name their doppelbox with the suffix
ator
to sort of imply a connection to that
solvator style
so you'll usually see that as part of
their name final style of the
bach family is icebach and conveniently
enough
ice eis in german translates to ice in
english
basically ice bach is a doppelbach
that has been frozen to concentrate its
flavors
water freezes at a higher temperature
than alcohol does
so as you cool beer down you'll be able
to
remove some of that frozen water leaving
you with like a more highly flavored
more intense
high alcohol product following this
freezing process you're left with an
incredibly potent beer
ice box can range all the way up to 14
alcohol
and they oftentimes will feature kind of
like
dark fruit or dried fruit notes things
like raisin
prune or or fig even
this group of hoppy lagers isn't broken
up into multiple sub families all of
these styles
are sort of derivatives of the
original pilsner style and that pilsner
style
is unquestionably one of the most
influential beer styles
in the history of beer so the first
style that we're going to talk about
is czech premium pale lager the style
name for this beard used to be
bohemian pilsner but was actually
changed
recently for a few reasons one pilsner
is a german word so
it doesn't really make sense for the
czech style to
carry a german name but
two in the czech republic pilsner is not
a style of beer pilsner is a brand you
may have heard of the beer pilsner or
kel
that is this original pilsner style
but in the czech republic that's the
only beer that
carries the name of pilsner now pilsner
raquel was
first brewed in late 1842 and
upon appearing on the scene it totally
transformed
beer across all of continental europe
the beer combined
several kind of unique or novel
characteristics it was brewed with very
soft water from the town of pilsen which
allowed for a beer that had a higher
than normal level of bitterness
but kind of like a soft pleasant quality
of bitterness that people really enjoyed
it also was one of the first truly pale
golden beers produced
leveraging you know new advances in
malting technology that for the first
time allowed pale malts to be produced
affordably on a large scale when you
look at the majority of the beer
produced around the world today you know
a lot of it falls
into the categories of things like
american lager american light lager
international pale lager all of those
styles are descended
from this one beer continuing on a
similar theme we have
czech pale lager which is kind of like a
lighter version of the czech premium
pale lager you know it's a
little bit lower in malt flavor a little
bit lower in body a little bit lower in
alcohol content
the german pill style is probably the
closest
direct descendant of the czech premium
pale lager style
this was basically german brewers
copying the czech pilsner style
to try to produce a similar beer using
the ingredients that they had
available to them at this point today
you're far more likely to find
brands of german pills than you will of
brands of czech premium pale
outside of pilsner or cow on the whole
uh
german pills is a really refreshing and
crushable style for those of you not
acquainted with the term
crushable is like drinkable but better
the first iterations of the american
lager style which is so prevalent today
were made by german immigrants to the us
in the
mid 1800s so like czech premium
pale lager very directly gave rise to
the german pill style
german pills very directly sort of
birth the american locker style next up
is german-like beer
which is basically german light beer
though you know
compared to our american light beer it's
a significantly more
assertive beer german hellas export beer
falls somewhere between
uh german pills and immunities typically
has a little bit more bitterness than a
helles would
but a little bit more body than you'd
expect to see in the pills
many of the classic examples of this
style come from the city of dortmund
and the style actually used to be called
dortmunder export
kolsch is another example of an ale that
i snuck into a lager
category but because of the way that the
fermentation
is handled kolsch usually doesn't have
tons and tons of fermentation
character a lot of times it's described
as sort of like the ale version of a
german pills
the coal style comes from the german
city of cologne
the german name for that city is cold
and kolsch literally means
of coal the service tradition of the
style
in the city of cologne is incredibly
unique and a lot of fun if you've
ever been or you ever get the chance to
go it's just an awesome experience
kolsch is served in these little rod
shaped glasses they're 200 milliliters
so
just over six ounces which obviously
does not take very long for you to drink
through
but the way that it's served is that
servers run around
with trays full of kolsch and as soon as
you finish one glass
they replace you with a fresh glass and
just make a tick on your coaster
and they just keep going and going and
going until
you put your coaster over the top of
your glass telling them that it's time
to stop
even though kolsch is only moderate and
alcohol content like four and a half
percent
and it's served in small glasses given
the
ease of consuming them and the rate at
which they're replaced
it's very easy to you know be conversing
with friends and look down and see like
10 or 15 tick marks on your coaster so
very fun
somewhat dangerous but always a good
time
last in the group is pre-prohibition
lager which
is a historical style that you don't see
a lot of commercial examples today but
it's kind of
a an interesting style because it
represents
the the link between german pills
and american lager pre-prohibition lager
approximates the beer
that german immigrants would have been
brewing when they first
came to the us in the mid-1800s and were
trying to recreate the german pill style
using the ingredients that they had
available to them here
now prohibition through the prohibition
of alcohol consumption
obviously put a lot of breweries out of
business which in and of itself would
have been pretty bad for the beer
industry but it came at a pretty bad
time
you know around the same time of
prohibition we had
a couple world wars we had the great
depression
so all of those sort of events together
conspired to really decimate the brewing
industry we went from a place where
there were thousands of breweries in the
country to
having less than 100 by the time you got
to like the
60s and 70s as a result of all of these
events
what we saw happen was beer before
prohibition was a lot more varied there
were a lot more different styles a lot
more flavorful beers
beer beyond like world war ii
we were kind of in american lager
territory where
most beer tasted exactly the same there
wasn't a lot of variety
it wasn't a very exciting thing to drink
it was just a commodity product
in addition to prohibition that really
shaped that was just kind of like the
general trends in consumer products
that occurred in the 50s you had a lot
of people moving from urban centers to
suburban areas a lot of people spending
less time in bars and more time at home
it's kind of like the tv dinner era and
so at that same time
across consumer products not just with
alcohol you had a move
from like smaller batch more kind of
like mom and pop products
to like mass-produced homogenized
products and happen in every industry
you look at like
toothpaste like there's how many
toothpaste brands can you name
how many laundry detergent brands can
you name like there are just a few
and they're all relatively similar what
really impressed people in the 50s
was not like this is a really flavorful
thing they're like
it's really cool that i can go anywhere
in the country and i can get something
that's exactly the same
so it was kind of that mentality that
shaped all consumer products
in that era and it was more kind of a
move
in food and beverage and eventually
other things towards artisanal products
like you can point to like starbucks as
sort of the rise
of people going from like coffee is just
a thing i drink for caffeine to like
coffee is the thing i drink for certain
flavors
that sort of lined up with people
getting into craft beer or craft spirits
or like all of those things
beer developing when it did was a
broader dynamic of people
wanting variety in all of the products
that they were looking at
due to the way that ales are fermented
they typically will show
some amount of flavor derived from their
fermentation
usually a little bit of fruity character
all of the beers in this group lead
with malt flavor though some of the
beers
also have significant levels of either
hot flavor or fermentation derived
flavor
to structure this group we went with
beers that range from kind of pale to
brown in color
first style here is dark mild which is
sort of like
your classic multi-british pub beer
very highly sessionable beer which is a
term that's used to describe beers that
are
lower in alcohol that you can drink
several of over the course of
a session it goes great alongside a lot
of pub fair like
i love drinking dark mild with classic
bangers and mash
british brown ale is balanced a lot like
a dark mild
though it's a bit stronger in strength
maybe up around
four to five percent alcohol content
think something like a newcastle brown
ale
also in the family of brown british ales
we have the
london brown ale style it's at this
point considered a historical style
there are very few examples of it
available
english barley wines are often
considered to be a mulch showcase you
know
with really robust notes of
caramel toffee but also like molasses
treacle
maybe some dark fruit character like
plum prune or fig
they're really robust and interesting
beers
in most cases barley wines are going to
be
the strongest products produced by a
given brewery
and they're usually also going to be
vintage dated in part because
due to their high alcohol content they
can age pretty well
next up in this category we have the
sort of generic
british strong ale style which serves as
sort of a catch-all for a lot of
higher alcohol english malty beers
compared to barley wine it's usually
going to be a little bit lower in
alcohol
in sort of like the six to eight percent
range rather than
eight to twelve percent like barley wine
last
among the british malty ales we have the
old ale style
which is similar in strength to
british strong ale typically features
some amount of
aged character which can go in a lot of
different directions
however like british strong ale this is
a style that allows for a pretty wide
range of interpretations
it's not the most popular of styles so
you don't see tons of examples of the
style in the market these days
we've got five different styles that fit
in the subgroup of scottish and irish
multi-ales
and the first three of them scottish
light scottish heavy and scottish export
are all very very closely related these
three styles
are very similar in their flavor
profiles and are primarily just
separated by different levels of alcohol
content and consequently differing
levels of intensity the light
is usually somewhere between 2.5 and 3
alcohol scottish heavy will be maybe
three to four percent and scottish
export might be
four to six percent alcohol scottish
light and heavy
are rather challenging to find outside
of scotland and honestly are even
somewhat difficult to find in scotland
the most commonly available
beer of this style that you'll see out
on the market is belhaven scottish ale
which is a classic example of the
scottish export style
then we have we heavy which is kind of
like an amped up version of the other
scottish ales
we heavy has similar flavors but
can range from like 6 to 10 alcohol
so the flavor is a lot more intense one
thing that is notable about these four
scottish styles
some people sometimes think that they
should be made
with peated malt you know pete is kind
of that like
really intense smoky character that you
get in certain types of scotch whiskey
however peated malt is used exclusively
in whiskey production it's not
typically used by scottish beer brewers
so
those sorts of flavors are not
appropriate in these styles
heading over to ireland we have irish
red ale which
is sort of a light refreshing irish
ale a lot of beers that
feature sort of a reddish hue are often
going to be produced with a specific
type of malt known as caramel malt
irish red ale sometimes will use caramel
malt but
more often will get its red color from
using a very very small amount of roast
barley
the ingredient that you know makes beers
like irish stout
black and heavily roasty in character we
have four different american multi-ale
styles that cover
a pretty wide range of different
characteristics and we're starting off
with american blonde ale
as the name implies american blonde ale
is a golden
pale colored beer american blonde ale is
meant to be a really
approachable beer and in a lot of cases
serves as sort of a
transitional beer for people moving from
beers like american lagers into beers
that have
a bit more flavor from a flavor
perspective
american wheat beer is pretty similar to
american blonde ale
though as the name implies it's made
with some amount of malted wheat
once again this is a relatively
straightforward beer it's a popular
style with a lot of early american craft
breweries
as a way to move people beyond
american lager beers that they might
have been more familiar with
in the 90s a lot of pioneers of the
american craft beer
movement had flagship beers that were
of the american wheat style you know you
can look at
goose island with three one two whitmer
with their hefeweizen has two really
prominent examples
for a pretty dramatic change of pace we
jump to
american brown ale american brown ale
is sort of like the american take on the
british brown ale style
in a lot of times when american brewers
adapt a style from somewhere else
they're going to make a beer that is
usually more aggressive
in some way in my opinion american
brownnail is a pretty underappreciated
style i have a
pretty deep love for the style it makes
for a really fantastic companion
with a wide range of different foods i
wish that there were more of them out
there
with wheat wine we have a unique
specialty beer that's kind of made
in the same vein as barley wine though
it also includes a pretty significant
portion of
wheat malt the style is rather high in
alcohol and drinks kind of like an amped
up version
of an american wheat beer next up we've
got a pair of malty ales from
continental europe
one from belgium and one from france
most classic belgian beer styles
are dominated by yeast derived flavors
but
uh belgian pale ale is pretty maltrevin
it doesn't have as much yeast character
as most other belgian styles
honestly belgian pale ales are kind of
hard to come by these days
there are two main producers in belgium
dakonic and palm and those are two of
the
best and potentially only examples of
the style that you can
find bearded guard is a french
specialty it's produced in the northeast
of france kind of along the border with
belgium
and it's an interesting style in that
it's produced in
three different color bands you have
blonde bearded guard amber bearded guard
and brown bearded
kentucky common is a historical style
it's very rarely seen commercially today
and the beard drinks a lot like a
dark version of a cream ale and then
last in the category
we have sati sati is a very
unusual finish style and i actually had
a hard time pinning exactly
where i wanted to put this one because
it has so much going on in it
the driving flavors of the style the
most prominent one being juniper
sati uses juniper berries as a flavoring
and the other place where people might
be familiar
with the juniper flavor is as sort of
the main flavor
in gin so sati has kind of a gin like
piney herbal floral character to it that
really drives the flavor profile of the
style
next up we've got a slate of 12 roasty
dark ales
this group covers a number of different
porters and stouts all of which are
brown or black in color
and feature some amount of roast flavor
originally stout grew out of porter as a
stronger version
of porter but today that's not
necessarily the case
english porter was a tremendously
popular
style in the uk in the 1700s and had
kind of a unique production process
at the time it was a beer that was made
as a blend of both young and old ales
so some of the beer would have been aged
in
large wooden bats where it would develop
acidity and kind of like funky
characteristics
then that would be blended with younger
beer to produce the finished
porter style english porter today does
not reflect that process
it's just kind of like a dark ale style
every
porter and stout sub style currently in
existence can be traced back to this one
style of beer
the majority of the beer made in the
world is made with four specific
ingredients
malt hops yeast and water and
through using different varieties of
those ingredients
and manipulating the way that those
ingredients are used brewers are able to
achieve a tremendous variety of
different flavor profiles in their beers
today in a lot of modern styles brewers
may augment that list of ingredients
perhaps adding things
as run-of-the-mill is like chocolate or
coffee or certain
fruits to like really weird ingredients
like
lobsters or zebra mussels or other
shellfish by and large the majority of
beer achieves
this wide palette of flavors using just
those four ingredients
the heyday of porter in the uk was very
much
the 1700s it sort of declined in
popularity
over the course of the 1800s and then
basically died out in the 20th century
however the porter style was sort of
resurrected by american craft brewers
looking for styles to experiment with
baltic porter is another take on the
porter style in this case brewed
in countries that sort of surround the
baltic sea some of the
more prominent commercial examples come
from like
sweden russia and poland
baltic porter stands out of this group
in that it's
actually usually made as a lager rather
than an ale
in part due to the colder climates of
the countries where this beer is
typically produced
at the time when this beer was
originally being made it would have been
easier for them to
do a logger fermentation than a nail
fermentation baltic porters will usually
be
anywhere from six to ten percent alcohol
lastly we have
pre-prohibition porter pre-prohibition
porter
is another historical style not very
widely available today
honestly hard to find in commercial
settings it's
a recreation of what porter might have
looked like
around the time of the revolutionary war
in the u.s
and at that point it was very much an
american brewers take
on the english porter style in the
mid-1700s when porter
was extremely popular brewers didn't
have a lot of options available to them
when it came
to making different styles of beer you
know ingredient availability was an
issue you
would have maybe one or two different
malts to choose from
as a result the primary way for brewers
to expand their offerings
was for them to brew beers of different
strengths
basically to use different amounts of
ingredients in the beers that they
brewed
stout grew out of this tradition as a
stronger version of porter
and all of these different levels of
stouts were
basically differing alcoholic strengths
of beers that resembled porter today the
key differences
between each of the stout substyles
often comes down to
the balance of the beer and the strength
of the beer
first up in the stout family we have
irish stout which is probably the best
known stout substyle as a result of the
widespread popularity of guinness draft
i actually think that irish stout is one
of the most misunderstood beer styles
out there
people look at this beer and they see
that it's dark and so
there are a lot of assumptions that come
with that people think that because it's
dark it's going to be
full bodied and high in alcohol and
assertively flavored
and basically none of those things are
true and as a result
it's actually like a pretty easy
drinking beer
irish stout gets its dark color and
it's heavily roasted flavor from the use
of roasted barley which is kind of the
signature ingredient in that style
another unique aspect of the irish stout
style is that it's often served on nitro
which means
it's served using nitrogen instead of
just carbon dioxide
the inclusion of nitrogen is what
creates that sort of cascading
bubbles effect that you see when a beard
like guinness is poured
and it also has some pretty distinct
impacts
on the flavor experience of the beer
it ends up reducing the perceived
bitterness of the beer
and also gives it kind of like a
smooth creamy texture just because you
encounter that really creamy head
first when you drink the beer the next
two styles
irish extra stout and foreign extra
stout are rather
similar to irish stout in terms of their
balance the main differences here
come down to the alcohol content and
consequently the
sort of the overall intensity of the
style
irish extra style is going to be a
little bit stronger than an irish stout
maybe
five to six percent in alcohol foreign
extra is
stronger still maybe six to eight
percent alcohol the tropical stout sub
style
is descended from some of those export
type stouts that would have been sent
to tropical locations such as the
caribbean or even like parts of india
the style is similar in strength to
foreign extra stout but the balance is
pretty different it's usually a lot
sweeter
american stout is the american take
on the foreign extra stout style and
like most american interpretations of
styles
it got made a little bit more intense
tending more towards kind of that
burnt ashy robust espresso
flavor imperial stout is the strongest
of all of the stout
substyles the style guidelines say that
it can go up to 12
alcohol but in truth you know you see
some
variations of the style that go higher i
can think of imperial stouts
up around 15 or even 18 alcohol in the
late 1700s these really really high
octane stouts were very popular with
the russian imperial court as an export
beer
and so a lot of brewers in the uk
took to naming their strongest stout
beers as
imperial stouts or russian imperial
stouts interestingly enough this is
where we get
the word imperial from as it is applied
to beer styles you'll see
you know on beer labels imperial porter
or imperial ipa imperial pilsner
that just means a stronger version of
the style and that's tied back to kind
of this
the history of imperial stout usually
meant to be
a sipper definitely a beer you can sit
down and
enjoy over a period of time imperial
stats also are a really common candidate
for
barrel aging particularly spirit barrel
aging some of the first
beers aged in barrels were imperial
stouts aged in bourbon barrels and
that trend is very very popular today
our last two stouts sweet stout and
oatmeal stout are sort of moderate
strength stouts that are distinguished
primarily by the addition
of unique ingredients sweet stout
doesn't necessarily have to have
anything unique added to it
but oftentimes is going to be brewed
with the addition of lactose
in which case it's specifically referred
to as a milk stout the reason why
brewers use
lactose in these beers rather than any
other number of
sugars is that yeast cannot ferment
lactose yeast are in essence lactose
intolerant
by adding lactose that sugar remains in
the beer through fermentation
and gives you a sweeter fuller-bodied
finished beer
oatmeal stout as you might imagine is
made with the addition of oats
and interestingly enough the oats are
not necessarily
used for their flavor contribution oats
will sometimes give
these beers a little bit of a nutty
characteristic but the bigger impact is
that usually oats
will give beer sort of a luscious
velvety texture which is what brewers
are typically after when they use oats
to make this style
the happy ale category includes 21
different sub styles and
covers a wide range of hoppy ales from
various regions around the world now
depending upon how they're used hops can
impart either bitterness or aroma and
flavor to beer
the hops grown in different parts of the
world have different flavor
characteristics
our first group of hoppy ales are the
british hoppy ales and we start things
off with
english ipa sort of the beer that kicked
off a lot of these other styles
now the english ipa style is the
original ipa
style and it comes with a pretty widely
known story that
unfortunately is not terribly grounded
in reality
ipa stands for india pale ale and the
story goes
that when the british were colonizing
india
you had people working over there
soldiers etc
they were very thirsty and beer was
being shipped over there but it was all
going bad in transit
so the brewers had to develop this
hoppy high alcohol style in order to
slake the thirst of all of the people
over
in india however the real story is a
little bit
less romantic uh it turns out that at
the time
brewers were sending all sorts of beer
including porter and other pale ales
over to india and it was
making it there just fine in terms of
the high hopping rate
brewers at the time knew that beer that
was more highly hopped
would keep longer so anything that was
getting shipped to india
would be highly hopped due to the fact
that it had to
survive this long voyage before it was
consumed and lastly with regards to the
high alcohol content
most india pale ales clock in around six
to seven percent alcohol
that's maybe high by today's standards
but the british
ales of the day were often between like
five and ten percent alcohol
so they really would have been just like
moderate strength beers what is true
about the story however
is that this pale bitter beer
did become very popular in india and
eventually
became popular back in the uk at which
point
it developed that name india pale ale as
has been the case with many of these
styles
india pale ale's popularity has sort of
ebbed and flowed over the years
so the indian pale ale of the mid 1800s
is
not too close to the ipa that we
know and enjoy today however the india
pale ale style
did spawn a number of pale bitter styles
and sort of laid the foundation for most
of the pale bitter beers that today
exist in the uk and the us
the next three sub-styles are a group of
english pale ales
known as bitters they're direct
descendants of the ipa style
as with the scottish ales these three
styles are
primarily distinguished just based on
their alcohol content
going in order from low strength to high
strength
you have ordinary bitter best bitter
and strong bitter of the three sub
styles you're most likely to encounter
beers in the best bitter sub style
one of the more prominent examples being
london pride from fuller's brewery
lastly we have the british gold nail
style which is
paler in color than the other members of
this family and so consequently features
less malt flavor and aroma next we have
a group of three
average strength american hoppy ales and
we kick things off
with the american pale ale style
american pale ale is sort of the
original
american craft beer style you know in
the
early days of the craft beer movements
or the late 70s
and early 80s brewers were
looking for inspiration and oftentimes
they turned to
classic styles made in the uk a lot of
early american craft brewers learned how
to brew from
english home brewing texts so doing
like others before them had done like we
saw with german brewers trying to
recreate pilsner in america we have
american brewers trying to
recreate english bitters but using
american ingredients
classic american hops tend to feature a
lot of
citrus flavor notes like grapefruit and
tangerine
as well as some kind of like piney
resony sorts of flavors
it doesn't get quite as much love as it
deserves these days but like it's
such an awesome and amazing style and
still one i go back to all the time
the american amber ale style is
basically a slightly darker take on the
american parallel style
typically brewers would use a little bit
of caramel malt
in making this beer so you get a little
bit of kind of caramel toffee malt
flavor
and then the hops are usually dialed
back just a hair but otherwise it's a
very similar beer to american paleo
lastly we have the california common
style which is a
rather unique american innovation
exemplified by the anchor steam brand
originally this beer was known as steam
beer
and in california in the mid-1800s
through the early 1900s
there were a vast number of different
breweries making steam beers
however they all died out one by one and
in the end only the anchor
brewing company was left standing at
which point they took a
trademark out on the name of steam beer
the main thing that makes this style
unique is that it's actually fermented
with lager yeast
however it's fermented with lager yeast
at higher temperatures
so it ends up still giving you some of
those fruity fermentation
flavors as a result it's more or less
just kind of like a unique take on an
american amber ale
next up we have the giant category of
ipa sub styles there are nine different
styles that sort of fit
under this ipa umbrella and brewers are
constantly experimenting and trying new
things
it's entirely possible that by the time
this video comes out there will be
another ipa substyle in existence the
core
style of the ipa group is the american
ipa
american brewers of kind of the early
90s
interpretation of that historic english
ipa style more hop aroma and
more bitterness more alcohol just like
more everything
one of the things that keeps the ipa
style and really the whole ipa family
fresh and exciting is that
hop breeders and growers continue to
release
new varieties of hops that bring sort of
an additional pallet of flavors
to brewers arsenals at this point the
american ipa
style has been exported all across the
world today
american ipas are significantly more
popular with brewers in the uk than
english ipas are
you also can find american ipas
throughout
asia and central and south america where
they call it ipa
so very very versatile style extremely
popular
one that i'm sure many viewers are
familiar with then we have double ipa
the easiest way to think of double ipas
like american ipa but more
there was definitely a period of time
probably
in the 2000s and early 2010s where
breweries kind of were pushing to see
who could make the
the most bitter or most intense beer
double ipas
are definitely a product of that time
and that sort of like hops
arms race now the new england ipa style
sometimes referred to as
hazy or juicy ipa is a style
that really only came around in like the
last five years or so but
came into popularity very very quickly
and has come to become like a dominant
force
in the beer space the calling card for
these styles
is their hazy appearance a lot of times
these beers are so hazy that they're
almost kind of like opaque
might even look like a glass of orange
juice in some cases
and really favors kind of what people
term like juicy hot flavors so
think things like orange juice mango
pineapple kind of these really robust
tropical flavors
and then we have a whole host of
different specialty ipa categories
the first group that we talk about is
sort of color variations on the ipa
style
most classic ipas are either like pale
golden
or amber in color we have several
different variations that play
on different colored versions of ipa
the four that exist are white ipa
red ipa brown ipa and black ipa
so in the case of white ipa we have
wheat being used
in the case of red ipa oftentimes you're
going to see some amount of caramel
used to give it that reddish hue a
little bit of sweet caramel flavor
brown ipas will use some more heavily
toasted malts
think like a chocolate malt which will
give it toasty
brown bread or or maybe even light
chocolate flavors black ipas are going
to use
de-bittered black malts belgian ipa
involves
a variation on the way that the beer is
fermented
belgian yeast strains tend to be more
characterful than american yeast strains
producing a lot more like fruity
characteristics
and giving it an interesting blend of
fermentation characteristics and hop
flavors
the last ipa of the group is rye ipa
which unsurprisingly is made with rye
one common misconception that people
have is that rye brings this sort of
spicy caraway flavor and that
misconception
exists because rye bread is almost
always flavored with caraway
that's not the case though it's more
along the lines of like the difference
between
bourbon whiskey or a rye based whiskey
american barley wine
is the american take on the english
barley wine style
american barley wines are usually like
bracingly bitter and have a fair amount
of
hop flavor and aroma these are seriously
intense beers
definitely sipping beers american strong
ale is a bit of a catch-all category for
various imperial versions of hoppy
styles
think like anything labeled like an
imperial red ale or
or an imperial amber something in that
category
one early and well-known example of this
style was stone's arrogant bastard ale
it was just like a really aggressive
high alcohol
hoppy beer next up we have a german
bitter ale
talking about alt beer which is
indigenous to the town of
dusseldorf and this style
at least the production of the style has
a lot in common with the way that kolsch
is made
all beer is typically amber in color
with sort of like toasty bready malt
flavors
the alt-beer style is honestly kind of
challenging to find outside of
dusseldorf
however if you are ever in dusseldorf
the
four traditional alt beer breweries are
all located
in and around the ultrastop the old part
of the city
and are all within about a 15-minute
walk of one another
last up in the hoppy ale category we
have australian sparkling ale
australian sparkling ale is a unique
style typically only found in australia
and it's really typified
by the products from the coopers brewery
it's a little bit like an english bitter
but
typically going to be paler in color
with less malt flavor
and significantly higher carbonation
fruity and or spicy ales
we've got 12 total styles to cover here
and we're now
moving into beers that are dominated by
their fermentation flavors
it's worth noting for the most part the
beers in this category are not actually
made using fruit or
spices these flavors are coming entirely
from the fermentation
styles in these groups use very
expressive yeast strains that tend to
produce high levels
of a group of flavor compounds known as
esters
which commonly give beer fruity
characteristics think
like banana apple pear
sometimes peach some of the strains
used for beers in this group can also
produce a type of flavor compound known
as phenols
those phenolic flavor compounds usually
give beers spicy sorts of
characteristics along the lines of like
clove nutmeg or white or black
peppercorn
our first group of styles is the german
hephabytes and type styles so there are
a few words
worth knowing the translation of
heffa translates to yeast then the other
two words that are commonly used in
association with this style are either
vaisn
which translates to wheat or
vice which translates to white
so the first member of this family is
the vice beer style
and vice beer goes by a few different
names sometimes you'll see it labeled as
half a vitamin sometimes as half of ice
beer brewers of this style use a very
special yeast strain that gives the beer
a lot of
banana and clove flavor characteristics
these beers are also very very highly
carbonated you know when you see them
served they're usually served in these
tall vase like glasses that allow for
two or three inches of foam to form on
top
next up is dunkel's vice beer it has a
lot of
similar fermentation flavors to vice
beer so still that banana clove profile
but also gets the addition of some
amount of a darker colored malt
lastly in this category we have a beer
that's not truly
a vitamin beer this is rogan beer
it's a beer made with rye rather than
wheat it's more or less
a rye based take on the dukel's vice
beer style
the first one of the bunch whip beer is
actually made with spices though it does
also
usually have a character full
fermentation as well
belgian whip beer is usually spiced with
both coriander
and orange peel which gives it sort of
citrusy
floral notes this specific style
basically died out in the 1950s and
would have been probably totally lost to
the world were it not for this one guy
pierce ellis
who founded the who garten brewery
through his production
of this style he sort of slowly brought
it back to prominence
and today it's a popular beer style you
know
among both small and large breweries
it's just a beautiful easy drinking beer
cezanne is a really exciting yeast
driven style
that allows for a really broad range of
interpretations
and many people think of cezanne as sort
of the
quintessential farmhouse style when you
see a beer that's
labeled sort of like farmhouse
oftentimes it will fall into this ceson
category
[Music]
so the brand name duval actually
translates to devil and some people
surmise that the name is a reference to
how the beer can kind of sneak up on you
you know if you
have a couple of these sitting down and
aren't paying close attention
you might find yourself in a different
place than you intended as a result many
of the other
brands within this style that are
produced today bear allusions to the
devil you know you get names such as
brigand or lucifer beelzebub
so you see a lot of devil references
when it comes to these books
[Music]
lastly in the category of sort of these
fruity spicy ales we have a series of
four different monastic beers that are
also all typically
made in belgium now these beers
feature a numerical naming system the
style names are trappist single belgian
double
belgian triple and then the top one is
technically called belgian dark strong
but
is oftentimes referred to as quadruple
now there's no actual
doubling or tripling of any of the
ingredients or specific characteristics
of the beer
but the beers do get stronger as you
progress from single to quad
to this day a lot of these styles are
produced by
trappist breweries located in belgium
and other parts of the world
trappist breweries are housed within
trappist monasteries and have to follow
a number of strict guidelines in order
to have their beard labeled as trappist
and the beers are generally regarded
worldwide for their high quality
the trappist single style is probably
the least commonly seen of any of these
four
the single style also sometimes referred
to as like a potter's beer
is usually reserved for the monks at the
monastery where it's brewed
this is a beer that they would kind of
drink every day alongside
their meals and as such it's not usually
packaged or distributed very widely
belgian double is a traditional belgian
style dating back to
the early 1900s it was first produced at
the
trappist brewery west muller in the
1920s
belgian doubles are usually amber to
brown in color
and typically present with a lot of
flavors of like
brown sugar sometimes molasses maybe
even a little bit of chocolate however
as is the case with
many of these belgian styles belgian
double is actually a pretty highly
attenuated style which means that
most of the sugar has been fermented out
it's a dry beer with very
little little residual sugar belgian
triple dates to a similar time frame
as belgian double triple was first
brewed also by west mall in the 1930s
and is a pale beer belgian dark strong
ale
also sometimes known as quadruple drinks
a lot
like a strong version of a belgian
double
but usually two to three percentage
points higher in alcohol
tart and or funky beers pretty much any
time you encounter high levels of
acidity in beer
that's going to be the result of a
bacterial fermentation
usually bacteria that are producing
lactic acid
maybe also bacteria that produce acetic
acid
and now bacterial fermentation can sound
kind of scary
but lactic acid bacteria are the same
bacteria that
produce yogurt so some of those kind of
tart flavors that you might find there
are similar to the flavors that you
would encounter in these beers these
beers also sometimes incorporate
so-called wild yeasts
one of the most common that gets used is
a yeast
known as protanomyces sometimes just
referred to as brett and
the flavors that protandim is produces
in beer
don't always sound super pleasant on
first blush you know things like
horse blanket wet wool barnyard
there are characteristics that in
isolation don't necessarily sound like
they'd be good things
but at low levels they can offer a
really
pleasant point of complexity in these
beers so
first up in this category we've got two
different tart
german wheat beer styles the first is
berliner vice which
is traditionally bracingly acidic
usually very highly carbonated but still
due to its kind of light body and low
alcohol content
they're usually very refreshing beers
historically bars would sometimes serve
these beers with
flavored syrups one of the stranger ones
that was actually pretty prevalent was
a syrup known as woodruff syrup it had
flavors of kind of like
earth and hay but more unusual is like
bright green in color
these days there honestly aren't a lot
of berliner vices being made in germany
you're more likely to see
smaller craft brewers making the style
in places such as the u.s
style given its acidity lends itself
really well to the addition of fruit so
you'll see brewers adding things like
peaches or raspberries or any number of
different fruits to berliner by style
beers
goza is honestly a rather strange
historic tart wheat beer style that was
pretty obscure and virtually unheard of
10 years ago
but in the last decade has just exploded
in terms of its popularity
goza drinks kind of like a mix
of a berliner vice and a belgian whip
beer
so it has kind of the lactic acidity of
berliner vice
has the coriander that you get from
whippier but then it also has kind of
its own
unique twist in that ghosas are usually
made with the addition of
salt at low levels adding salt kind of
enhances the body and the perception of
sweetness of the beer
the remainder of the tart and funky beer
category is comprised of
five distinct styles that come from
belgium we'll start with these flanders
or flemish red and brown beards
belgians often don't make a clean
distinction between these two styles in
fact
belgians generally don't talk about
style nearly as much as we do
over here flanders red ale is a tart
red beer from western flanders
and the style is really typified by the
products from a brewery
named rodenbach in addition to their
acidity these beers feature tons of
fruit character
think like black cherry and currant
lots of fruit notes present in these
beers sometimes
these beers are referred to as like the
burgundies of belgium
due to their similarities or overlaps
with
certain red wines and in that vein this
is a beer that i very much
like to use with somebody who considers
themself a wine drinker but not a beer
drinker
i've definitely won over audiences of
wine drinkers
with this beer to develop their acidity
these beers are typically aged in really
large oak bats
of the two flanders styles food broon
is a little less common than flanders
red ale
but the style is indigenous to
east flanders and is typified by the
products from the leafmen's brewery the
last group of tartan funky beers that we
have to discuss
is the lambic family of beers and
honestly
i think that these are some of the most
fascinating beers made
anywhere in the world there are a number
of things that are very unique about the
way that lambic is produced but probably
the most
unusual facet of their production
is the way that they're fermented
normally
in the process of making beer brewers
first produce what is called
wort this is the sugary and hopped
liquid
that then gets fermented by yeast
however
landmakers take a very different
approach instead
following the production of the work
they transfer that work into a cool ship
where they allow it to cool overnight
cool basically being a large
shallow
basin and as the work
cools the bacteria and yeast present in
the air in the brewery begin to grow
in the work essentially spontaneously
inoculating the the word
the base beer produced in this way is
generically referred to as lambic and
lambic
is a style in and of itself sometimes
you will see
straight lambics served however that's
rather rare
you're far more likely to see this
lambic beer
after it has aged for a couple years
being used to produce
two other more common styles goose and
fruit lambic
so goose is typically a blend of several
different vintages of lambic beer
usually
some amount of one year some amount of
two year and some amount of
three-year-old
lambic beer after these different
vintages of lambic are blended together
the beer
is re-fermented in the bottle to achieve
a very very high level of carbonation
when it's finished it almost drinks kind
of like a
like a funky champagne lastly we have
fruit lambic which
once again is taking that sort of tart
funky base lambic beer
but then the brewer is going to add
fruit to it and allow
the fruit to go through another
fermentation the most common fruits that
you see used for these beers are
raspberries in which case the beer is
known as francoise
or cherries in which case the beer is
known as creek
the final category we're covering is
smoked beers
and there are only three traditional
styles that we're covering in this
category
but they have such a unique flavor and
such unique characteristics that
they really just couldn't be put
anywhere else
now there are a few different ways that
brewers can impart smoky flavors to beer
but the most common one is going to be
through the use of smoked malt
basically during the last stage of the
melting process when the malt would
normally
be dried with hot air instead it's dried
with air from some sort of fire that
imparts
those smoky flavors and characteristics
furthermore the specific flavors that
you get from those smoked malts are very
much
determined by what fuel is used for the
fire
the first smoke style that we'll cover
is the german style ralph beer
rauc is the german word for smoke so
rock beer just means
smoked beer in german the malts that get
used to make
classic german rock beer are going to be
smoked with beechwood
which gives characteristic flavors of
ham
bacon or sort of like campfire notes but
some of these beers particularly the
ones that feature
high levels of smoked malt can be
downright
meaty in character the second beer that
we're talking about in this family is a
beer known as pivo grotzitsky
also sometimes referred to as great sir
and this is a
polish smoked style and it's made with
oak smoked malt
now oak smoke tends to be a little bit
softer
than beechwood smoke so while this beer
is still typically fairly intense in its
smoke character
it's definitely a bit softer and more
approachable than a classic ralph beer
often is
the beer is also very highly carbonated
and pretty low in alcohol
so well you might not think of a beer
that tastes kind of
meaty as being a refreshing beer it's
actually
a pretty easy drinking beer
and lastly we have lichtenheiner which
is a
true historical oddity one way to think
of it is basically like a smoked
bird winter vice but with a little bit
softer acidity to it
while 100 different beer styles
definitely covers a lot of ground
there's still a fair amount of beer on
the market today that doesn't
neatly conform to a specific beer style
commonly brewers will take an existing
style and modify it either using
unique ingredients or perhaps a unique
technique to produce
an entirely new creation so one common
variation is beers that fall into the
broad group of american wild ales
this would be a brewer taking a style
and using either bacteria or wild yeast
to ferment it like we saw in some of
those tart and sour beers
two really common categories of
variations
involve both fruit beers and spiced
beers
beers where brewers are going to be
adding some sort of fruit or some sort
of spices
in some cases a mix of the two in order
to create something interesting
some beers will leverage alternative
sources of fermentable sugar
most beer is going to be made with
malted barley
some beers also include things like
malted wheat but there's
a bunch of other ingredients that can be
used things like oats spelt
rye millet or even things like
molasses or agave smoked beer is another
somewhat common variation we talked
about three
specific styles that use smoked malt in
their production
brewers today tend to experiment all the
time and so
you can make any style into a smoked
style by
adding smoked malt to it wood aging is
another technique that brewers can use
to create variations on their styles
there are a lot of different types of
barrels that brewers can use but
in a lot of cases you'll see brewers
using
spirit barrels things like bourbon or
other types of whiskey
maybe rum barrels sometimes even like
tequila barrels
and then the last category is just a
total catch-all for
whatever weird things brewers are
cooking up these days
this is specialty beers and this kind of
includes
mixes of some of the above categories if
a brewer wanted to make like a
smoked beer with fruit or like a
barrel-aged beer with spices
that's where this would fall
[Music]
all right well that was each and every
beer style
i don't know about you guys but all this
talking about beer has made me pretty
damn thirsty
i had a lot of fun talking to you guys
and i really hope that all this
helps you find new beer style to enjoy
cheers
you